[Ukraїner
Країна ззовні]
[Гамбург,
Німеччина]
Я з Тернополя, народилася в Тернополі.
Я, насправді, зовсім не планувала ніколи Німеччину.
А потім в нашім серці «ся зашпортала любов»
[відсилка до пісні «В Стрийськім парку»].
[сміється]
Тому це був переїзд до Мартіна.
Це взагалі... Тобто Німеччина там не стояла як питання.
Ну але Німеччина...
[видихає]
Не так погано тут.
[сміється]
Мартін якийсь-такий видався,
що в багатьох життєвих моментах дуже схожий на мене.
Я підкидаю Мартіну кліп «Мертвого Півня»
[українського рок-гурту],
бо «Мертвий Півень» — це мої однолітки,
це для мене така дуже знакова група.
У них є кліп з Кашою Сальцовою
[українською співачкою] «Ми помрем не в Парижі»,
і я це закидаю Мартіну.
І Мартін так: «Вау!»
Він це зрозумів!
Другий був цікавий момент:
якраз тоді вийшов німецький переклад «Музею покинутих секретів»
Забужко [української письменниці та поетеси].
І я так: «Мартіне! А є така книжка,
ось вийшла у вас німецькою».
Проходить кілька днів,
Мартін каже: «Я вже її купив».
Ще кілька днів проходить: «Я її вже прочитав».
Отакий том [показує товщину книги].
Я думаю, якщо людина прочитала і
зрозуміла цей текст,
і це її текст так, як це мій текст,
то дійсно щось є спільного.
— Так помаленьку, помаленьку...
— Так, музика була важлива.
У нас у Гамбурзі є кілька українських товариств,
але кожне собі вибрало свою
специфічну ділянку роботи.
Тому в нас немає одного великого,
а є більше таких дуже згуртованих команд,
які між собою співпрацюють,
але кожен має свою ділянку.
Хтось гуманітарку відправляє,
хтось (наприклад волонтери) —
опікується пораненими,
у нас тут у госпіталі лікувалися.
І ми потім знаходимо якісь точки перетину й допомагаємо.
У мене вже, звичайно, був український бекґраунд.
Я був у Львові, у Католицькому університеті,
на літній школі трохи ще далі вчив українську.
У мене взагалі було бажання
трохи краще знати українську мову.
Якщо ти хочеш розуміти людину з іншої країни,
просто треба знати мову,
тому що мова — це джерело душі,
ментальності людини.
Весільний ранок!
Молоді збираються до шлюбу.
— Слава Ісусу Христу!
— Слава навіки!
Яка там була Пасха сумна,
але ми сиділи вдома і через інтернет
дивилися службу.
І не могли співати самі.
Ну це просто було жахливо.
Хотів мати контакт з українцями,
просто щоб далі вчити мову.
І тому я вирішив дивитися на українську церкву,
яка була в нас у Гамбурзі.
Там мені дуже подобалося:
дуже приємні люди, дуже гарна атмосфера.
І за якийсь час я познайомився
з сином священника — Павлом.
І якось у нас створилася та ідея,
що було би гарно мати справжній хор.
Шукали диригента, але без успіху.
І потім був такий момент,
коли Павло мені просто сказав:
«Мартіне, я думаю, що ти це зробиш».
Тоді...
Я думаю, що це було на Пасху
(я не зовсім вже згадаю тоді),
але ми просто ходили через церкву
і просто слухали, які люди там
у залі гарно співали.
Після того ми ходили до них і запитували:
«Ми плануємо створити хор.
Чи хочете з нами співати?»
І тоді там була маленька група людей,
які захотіли співати.
І в мене була проблема, тому що я не мав
жодного матеріалу і не знав, що з ними робити.
[сміється]
Я не знав, як диригувати.
Тоді ще в мене були уроки співу.
Я приїхав до свого викладача і сказав йому:
«Знаєш, я тепер маю хор. Я не знаю, що робити!
Я не знаю, що робити з руками!»
Він сказав: «Без проблем! Я тобі покажу».
♪ [співає хор] ♪
Ми — суто літургійний хор.
Це означає, що ми не виступаємо десь інакше
[поза церквою].
Як-то кажуть, добрі українці обов'язково
хоча би на Пасху приходять до церкви.
Ну й коли звичайні дні, там один склад,
то на Пасху до церкви приїжджають,
загалом, люди зі всього регіону.
Виходить така просто народна зустріч!
Цього року було інакше,
і якось нам, що співати не можна...
Без співу вже церква — не церква,
вже чогось бракує.
Ей, привіт!
Як справи?
[імітує нявкання]
[сміється] Отак!
Тосі!
Я працюю у сфері ІТ [інформаційних технологій].
Я всі ноти пишу програмою LilyPond.
Це означає, що я дійсно програмую музику.
Там є така мова, якою я пишу всі ноти й тексти.
І вона мені просто робить ті ноти й медіафайли.
Дуже люблю українські колядки, особливо ті обробки
композиторів, як-от Стеценка, наприклад.
Особливо було нам важливо співати «Щедрик»,
тому що це найвідоміша українська пісня,
про яку звичайні люди просто не знають,
що це — українська [пісня].
Німцям це страшно подобається,
вони дуже люблять такий стиль музики.
І це також такий елемент культурної дипломатії,
тому що ми просто можемо показати
звичайним німцям обличчя України,
яка, скажімо, не політична.
Це не те, що люди бачать у новинах.
Тому це дуже цікава частина української культури,
яку можна показати німцям.
♪ [співають «Щедрик»] ♪
Я думаю, що дуже важливо показати німцям
трохи більше про справжню Україну:
як люди живуть, яка в них ментальність,
які вони мають традиції.
І це важливіше, ніж політики,
що там робиться, який там президент тощо.
Тому що це просто люди не згадають.
Ну там буде ще наступний,
наступний і наступний [президент].
Тут дуже важливий позитивний
імідж України у світі.
І, властиво, перелом стався в момент Майдану,
коли світ побачив, що є люди,
які готові віддавати життя за європейські цінності,
що це не просто слова.
І дуже важливо підтримувати саме цей...
позитивний образ України,
яка є частиною європейської культури.
Ми, власне, завжди наголошуємо.
У часи Радянського Союзу це була інформація закрита.
Тобто представляли якийсь абстрактний Радянський Союз.
Тут навіть гастролювали...
Тут були такі Kosaken [козаки].
Ті Kosaken,
[у них] там тих українських пісень добра половина.
Але їх представляли, що це Kosaken,
що це — Росія, [німецькою] донські козаки.
І тепер треба відвойовувати це і показувати,
що це — українське,
що в Україні було бароко, наприклад.
Ніхто собі не уявляв, що в Україні є своя традиція.
Коли я навіть Мартіну розповіла,
Мартін такий: «Вау, а що там в Україні було?»
Ми розказуємо: «Так, і література була,
і живопис, і архітектура, і музика».
Ми сконцентрувалися найбільше
на літературних зустрічах, бо це мій профіль,
і легше десь контакти знаходити,
коли ти є в тому середовищі.
Ми побачили, що культурою можна
дуже багато чого зробити.
Іде такий процес впровадження України
і віднайдення того місця, яке ми колись втратили.
Ми ж були, просто нас відсунули,
нас відкинули, нас ізолювали,
щоб ми десь кудись не прорвалися.
І тут, особливо завдяки молодому поколінню,
воно дуже вже гарно починає працювати.
Так... Цак!
[Субтитрувальниця
Леся Любченко]
[Ukraїner
Країна ззовні]
[Проєкт реалізовано за підтримки
Українського культурного фонду]